[Música]
[Aplausos]
bueno yo os quiero comentar como habéis
visto soy periodista y me dedico a
viajar en moto por el mundo es una cosa
que empecé a hacer en 2011 y que no he
podido dejar de hacer me ha picado el
del viaje y me ha vuelto loca y lo
que os quiero contar como ya estamos
hablando de ser inexactos o de la
inexactitud de la vida os quiero contar
que los viajes son súper inexactos pero
que estas cosas inexactas incorrectas
equivocadas erróneas son las que nos
ayudan a aprender a superarnos y
advirtió a aventuras no hay que tener
miedo a las palabras negativas porque
enseguida le damos una vuelta y las
transformamos en palabras positivas
sobre todo esto para todos los jóvenes
los jovenzuelos que estáis ahí que lo
sepáis que no hay que agobiarse que no
hay que ser la persona más exacta para
pasarlo bien o para aprender por ejemplo
cosas que me ocurren a mí en los viajes
una conducción incorrecta que dirías qué
horror te has caído en la arena te
podías haber hecho daño en un pie se
podía haber roto la moto pues no señores
esto te da más seguridad
pues porque al hacerlo mal y caerte y
levantar la moto y volverte a poner
encima uno dice oye ya no me da tanto
miedo de la arena ya sé que si me caigo
me pasa esto y después solo tengo que
recoger la moto y seguir el camino estoy
aprendiendo me está dando mucha
seguridad
así que habéis visto una palabra fe y ya
que es algo incorrecto que siempre nos
han explicado que tenemos que hacerlo
todo correctamente que tenemos que
escribir con buena letra que tenemos que
no señores tenemos que fallar y tenemos
que ser inexactos y en este caso nos da
seguridad
que más cosas nos pueden pasar bueno
pues os voy a contar una anécdota para
que veáis
que cuando uno hace algo de manera
incorrecta es la mejor oportunidad que
nos da la vida para hacerlo de manera
correcta por ejemplo en la como estáis
leyendo ahí estuve cuatro días parada en
la frontera de mongolia con rusia en una
frontera que está entre un lado bator
qué es la capital de mongolia ulan ude
que es una ciudad grande que está al
lado del lago baikal estuve cuatro días
en un agujero porque era una frontera
muy chiquitita por la que sólo pasaban
camiones de carga un pueblecito en el
que sólo había dos hoteles y diego
hoteles entre comillas porque eso eran
unos camastros duros con un lavabo en un
pasillo y un baño que tenías que caminar
y salir fuera para poder hacer un pipi
y llegaba a la frontera y me decían los
mongoles que no podía pasar con esta
moto que no eran los papeles correctos
que no me dejaban pasar vuelvo al día
siguiente otra vez vuelvo a ir a las 12
de la mañana que ya estaba un poco
cansada a ver si conseguía pasar y me
vuelven a decir que no que no que esos
papeles no eran los correctos y que no
podía pasar y todo que me empiezan a
decir los amigos mete dinero en el
pasaporte y cuando lo entregues
seguramente te dirán pasa pasa de humano
me muero de vergüenza y como el señor
agassi coja el dinerito se lo guarde y
me diga que no pasa es que bueno regreso
otra vez al hotel tercer día por fin me
dejan pasar al lado ruso pero qué pasó
cuando llegué al lado ruso lo mismo que
cuando estaba en el lago mont en el lado
mongol que no me dejaban pasar iba con
un amigo que iba con otra moto que había
comprado en mongolia y no querían dejar
salir primero los mongoles la matrícula
mongola y después los rusos no querían
que un vehículo mongol entrara en su
país bueno ya desesperada de hacer las
cosas de manera incorrecta pensé
y si mañana nos levantamos a las 5 de la
mañana y estamos ahí a las 7 en punto
pasamos el lado mongol y llegamos al
lado ruso prontito que ya no estará la
señorita rottenmeier está que nos está
diciendo te reto que nieta que no vamos
a pasar bueno pues así lo hicimos lo que
había era un tío estupendo yo le dije al
otro espérate aquí me senté con él me
puse a simona le dije que me llevaban y
no y el otro dijo que estudiaba allí y
me enrollé a hablar con él y al final
cogió el sello que era lo único que
tenía que hacer punto y poner el sello y
por fin conseguí pasar qué pasa con todo
esto que un comportamiento incorrecto
que es lo que yo estaba haciendo la
manera de enfrentarme este paso
fronterizo en el momento que lo cambie
se solucionó y además me ha permitido
aprender muchísimo sobre el paso de
fronteras terrestres y ya no estas cosas
no me vuelven a pasar
otra de las cosas que nos puede suceder
en un viaje que además es esto es súper
normal porque yo voy con un navegador
que me dice por dónde tengo que ir pero
no me avisa si esto por donde me está
llevándose el buen o el mal camino yo me
fío de él entonces voy con mi navegador
malawi voy a pasar por la frontera más
al sur del país por la que no pasa nadie
vamos a vivir una aventura que además el
navegador me dice que este es el camino
perfecto mira en línea recta pasamos
hasta montañita y ahí llegó que pasó que
era mentira
el navegador debería tener el mapa del
año catapún porque por ahí lo único que
había era un camino de tierra como
estáis viendo ahí y cuando llegue a esta
frontera
me dijeron tiene usted el visado era una
frontera nada un camino de tierra con
una casita aquí una barrera que todo el
mundo pasaba andando y ahí al fondo la
bandera de del otro país tienes el
visado no lo compro ahí en uhf esta
frontera es tan pequeña que no tienen
visados no tienen el sello no puedes
comprarlo déjame pasar a ver pero es que
luego cuando vuelvas te voy a tener que
el dinero otra vez de entrar en el
país
madre mía tuve que dar la vuelta sin
dinero porque ya me había gastado todo
el dinero de malawi para no tener que
cambiar que no me iban a dar nada tuve
que regresar con sed con hambre sin
dinero me encontré con unos ríos que
tuve que cruzar tuve que pedirle al
barquero que me pasara la moto que ya le
pagaría cuando llegue al pueblo cajero
no funcionaba bueno fue tremendo fue una
gran equivocación pero que se ha
transformado en una bonita anécdota que
yo ahora cuento en todos estos viajes
más cosas cosas que hacemos mal cosas
erróneas durante un viaje que es como la
vida misma bueno pues por ejemplo otra
vez cruzando el altiplano en bolivia se
puso a llover mucho porque la época que
ellos tienen 22 estaciones la seca y la
lluviosa y el verano es la lluviosa y el
invierno es la seca pero de vez en
cuando caen también buenas tormentas
empapada y empapada en la moto empapada
mojada y sima y me dijeron en cuanto
veas un rayo de sol paras te quitas los
calcetines la camiseta lo pones todo el
tipo tenderete te secas lo más que
puedas
y luego continuar no hice ni caso tenía
tanta prisa en llegar a un hotel que
cuando salió el sol dijo hoy que gustito
se me va a sacar el guante por aquí y el
casco y qué pasó que cometí un grave
error cuando llegue el hotel que era por
la tarde no había sol y además no estaba
preparado el hotel como para tener
calefacción y que yo pudiera sacar todo
me tuve que quedar dos días allí
poniendo la ropa como la estáis viendo
aquí en la terraza para ver si con el
poco sol que había se iba quemando todo
y no tener se iba sacando todo y no
tener que volverme a poner las gotas
húmedas que pasó que de un
comportamiento erróneo saqué un
aprendizaje que es que si hay sol hay
que aprovecharlo siempre en todos los
viajes
por eso digo que los viajes igual que en
la vida porque los viajes
un viaje yo creo que equivale un año de
viaje a 10 de vida somos sin exactos y
es muy bonito que seamos inexactos eso
es lo que nos da personalidad lo que nos
permite aprender lo que nos permite
conocer a otras personas por cuando uno
se equivoca al final acabas pidiendo
ayuda para que alguien te eche una mano
así que tenemos que estar todos muy
contentos y no tener vergüenza de
preguntar tenemos que estar contentos
contentos de ser inexactos porque esto
nos permite tener aventuras anécdotas
aprendizajes y superar nuestros propios
miedos
lo tenéis claro por ahí que vosotros
sois el futuro de todo lo que viene no
tengáis miedo a equivocarnos no tengáis
miedo nadie a ser inexactos yo estoy
encantada de ser inexacta muchas gracias
a todos
gracias
[Aplausos]